are there any
problems you guys sit around together
and say listen these three problems
no one can solve human human cannot
solve do you guys think about certain
problems that there's no way we can
solve
uh well we would i would typically put
problems into
two separate piles okay over here you've
got
technical problems that technologies
might help with
and over here you've got problems
between people
or groups of people and that's out of my
jurisdiction right so
i can't i don't have any optimism about
being able to solve problems with human
decision making they
they seem to be unsolvable to me
and i think it's actually it's important
to think that way like
you know a lot of the problems that we
have are
created by humans they're created by
humans decisions and by their lifestyles
and their
and their patterns and and um
and their politics and this kind of
stuff and and so
no technology is going to solve that so
um i don't work on those
okay so we got technical we got people
group or
groups of people decision making let's
just say that's political you know
opinions pro-life pro-choice
we don't deal with that but on the
technical side is there anything you
look at where you say
i just don't know how we can solve that
one problem anything on that like
biowarfare i don't know if we can
control a buy or a cyber attack or i
don't know how we can solve
you know is there anything that for you
guys is the impossible
you know there's there if you take that
pile you can sort of break it down into
uh problems that require a miracle
and problems that do not require a
miracle got it so
in my lifetime you know we've had uh
we've needed a miracle in energy storage
okay that's why wind and solar are
problematic because you know we need a
way to store that energy
that's efficient we don't really have
that and we would love it and people
keep
coming up with ideas and trying to make
batteries better and stuff yeah
but to really make a difference we need
a miraculous discovery in energy storage
um another one has been uh quantum
computing
you know we've fantasized about these
amazing quantum computers
people are making a little bit of
progress here and there um
i think a lot of it's overstated we're
still a long ways from
having a quantum computer from
understanding how it would work and what
we would do with it
so we need a miracle or two in that
another big one is cold fusion
the way fusion reactors work is they
make energy the way the sun makes energy
and there's extraordinary power
available that's that would be
clean and cheap and free almost but
we've needed a miraculous breakthrough
in cold fusion
in order to be able to do that here on
earth um
and that's and that's something that you
know you can often uh spot these as
you know things that are just 20 years
from now if somebody says it's just 20
years from now that means well they're
hoping to get a breakthrough in the next
20 years but the breakthroughs like that
don't
don't happen on a schedule interestingly
with fusion
i think we might have just got there
by miraculous by miracle or by no
miracle required
actually by um by
figuring out how to take the
technologies we have and
and do it with them and so for the first
time in my life i
i've been convinced that i think that
fusion
might be imminent and that would be
amazing for us because
solving energy is the most important
problem ever if you solve energy
you kind of solve every other technical
problem for free
not all of them but a lot of them you
because if you have cheap clean abundant
energy
things like recycling could work um
you know things like uh cleaning you
know we could desalinate water we could
make water you could solve water
um if you had energy you could solve
sanitation like a lot of things like
that
that were held back by and if in a way
to think about this is the truth is
the reason americans are rich is because
we have access to
energy that's reliable and cheap
right that's really the main difference
between america and every other country
on earth
right americans on average get about
nine times as much energy
as the median human on earth
right we so much more energy is invested
in us
and that just me that's why we are rich
and so
you know we like to think we're rich
because we're you know smart geniuses
and so that's not it it's we're just
using a lot of energy and so the goal
should be to give everybody on earth as
much energy as we give an american
and we're not we're not getting close to
that we're not getting close
burning coal we're definitely not
getting there with wind and solar
yet um and so we need to build
nuclear reactors and we need some
breakthroughs
[Music]
you